[Music]
here we go again Sony have revealed the
free games for PS Plus subscribers for
the month of December 2019 usually at
Christmas time the PlayStation Plus
offerings aren't too great so don't
expect too much but I think they're
pretty good
anyway fYI you can download these games
from Tuesday the 3rd of December so
let's do this
game number one is titanfall 2 a
first-person military shooter which adds
wall running and mech exoskeletons which
drop into the warzone to assist you in
battle hence the title titanfall
titanfall 2 has both single-player and
multiplayer online options the campaign
was praised for the storytelling of Jack
Cooper a rifleman who bonds with a Titan
after the death of his mentor from there
Jack and his mech are tasked with
stopping an interstellar super weapon
from destroying the entire planet online
you'd be forgiven to think this is
another Call of Duty clone but titanfall
keeps to the sci-fi elements like the
aforementioned wall running while other
games have reverted back to boots on the
ground gameplay titanfall 2 was released
three years ago at a terrible point in
the year sandwiched between the new Call
of Duty game and Battlefield so it
didn't stand a chance maybe it will now
the reviews tell us that this is an
unmissable game there's numerous 9 out
of 10 scores from the publications you
trust all the game modes you'd expect
are here like Team Deathmatch and
capture the flag but other modes that
breathe extra life into the game such as
Titan brawl where everyone is given a
Titan which they cannot leave and bounty
hunt is another fun mode with money
being rewarded per elimination my advice
is to give it a go or to jump back in if
you have it already
hopefully the servers will be full again
and now our final game of 2019 Monster
Energy Supercross the official video
game well apart from humping a
ridiculously long title and painfully
over-the-top advertising of energy
drinks this is a dirt bike rally title
as it's official expect to see all the
tracks from the real competition and
this will make up the career mode a
single-player season where you ride to
be crowned champion if you prefer an
arcade feel of a realism or vice versa
the game allows you to tweak braking and
handling to make it feel unique to you
by moving your right stick your rider
will adjust their weight
to help with balance round corners or
during jumps but here is the best bit
rewind we can to a small degree go back
in time for a few seconds and redo
anything we've misjudged maybe on the
last lap you crushed hard rewind and
have a second chance
I like this mechanic it prevents
controllers from being smashed in fits
of stress I struggled to find reliable
reviews so we're gonna go with
Metacritic this time at present the ps4
version has a score of 67 out of 100 so
there we have it the last PS Plus games
of 2019 how do you feel about it which
are you grabbing but more importantly
how do you think the year is gone has it
been worth your money this year to have
PS Plus from January to December I'd
love to know what you think I'm Adam
from PlayStation granade been a pleasure
I'll see you soon